und jetzt kommen wir zu meiner absoluten
lieblings geschichte des tages schauen
sie sich mal genau dieses foto jetzt an
da geht einem doch wirklich das herz auf
das foto das hat tobias baumgartner
gemacht und damit auch einen preis
gewonnen
viel interessanter ist aber die
geschichte hinter diesem foto also genau
diese szene wurde er eine pinguinen den
anderen umarmt die beiden haben nämlich
jeweils ihren partner verloren und
seitdem treffen sich die beiden
trauernden tiere regelmäßig sie pushen
sich gegenseitig das gefieder und sind
füreinander da eben also so richtig
herzerwärmende szenen die wir hier sehen